(Amy)
Whoa, save some for the fish!
You're watching
"Gym Bummers."
♪
Welcome to Sports Central's
"Gym Bummers,"
the show about things
people do at the gym
that bum everyone out.
Let's kick off the show with
this week's highlights.
(Amy)
Our first Gym Bummer comes
to us from the Scrunch gym
in Montclair, New Jersey.
Here comes
supplement-pushing,
unsolicited advice
guy.
Doing the double tap.
Here we go, having him
take out his headphones,
about to land and...
You're doing it wrong.
(Amy)
Boom!
Avert your eyes, folks.
It's the co-dependent
couple
working out together.
(man)
Hey, why molest
each other
in the comfort
of your own home
when you can do it in
full view of everyone?
We understand
that shoulder presses
are part of your
foreplay,
but if we
wanted to watch,
we'd find your YouPorn
channel.
(alarm sounds)
Oh, you know what that
sound means.
It's time for
the lightning round.
Code red, code red.
Indian guy working out
in jeans.
Just gonna take a shot
in the dark here.
I don't think this
gentleman's gonna shower
after this gym visit.
Woman who dresses
like Mr. Mistoffelees
from the musical "Cats."
Guy who picks the treadmill
right next to you
when there's
plenty available
and runs sideways
facing you.
Man, I don't
think it's true
that poodles are
the smartest.
He's got nothing
to say
but wants
everyone to hear it.
That's a rare double
bummer.
It's the classic
grunt and drop.
(roaring)
Yeah!
Ugh.
Easy, Drago.
No one's invading
your village.
And that's the end
of the lightning round.
Whew, well, now it's time
for Bummer of the Week.
A fully-dressed
couple
who just
checked into a hotel
are surveying
the gym.
They didn't even bring
gym clothes.
"Yeah, wow, honey.
There are a lot
of towels in here."
Stop lying to yourselves.
You're never gonna use it.
You're never gonna use it!
And that's
all the time we have.
Tune in next week
for "Gym Bummers:
Locker Room Edition,"
where a naked old guy
with a hanging scrotum
blow-dries his hair
for 90 minutes.